Swiss banking has always been the center of
attention for Hollywood when it comes to sketchy
activities.
Whether we’re dealing with tax evasion or
securities fraud, Hollywood suggests that
Swiss banks are the go to safe haven.
While there is some truth to this notion,
this is not the primary reason that most individuals
choose to go with swiss banks.
In fact, the real reason likely applies to
you as well.
So, here’s why the rich really prefer swiss
banking and why you need a swiss bank account
today more than ever.
Starting off, let’s take a look at how Switzerland
even became famous for banking.
The strong reputation of Swiss banks isn’t
a new development by any means, it actually
stretches way back to the 16th century.
At the time, Europe was undergoing a massive
spiritual transformation.
The scientific findings of famous scientists
such as Leonardo da Vinci and Galileo raised
skepticism surrounding the existence of god.
We also had revolutionaries like Martin Luther
who challenged the control and teachings of
the Roman Catholic Church.
This surge of questioning long-lasting ideals
eventually erupted and led to the famous Protestant
Reformation.
Some rulers supported the reformation as this
meant they could take away power from the
church while others stood strong in their
support for the church.
The religious freedom in your country, however,
could change on a whim.
If the king passed away, it didn’t take
long for the son or daughter to take over
and potentially switch to the other side.
One of the only places, however, that was
consistently neutral on the subject was reformed
areas of Switzerland including Geneva, Basel,
and Zurich.
This neutrality attracted a large number of
Huguenots and Protestant refugees from all
over Europe.
Geographically speaking, Switzerland is literally
in the center of present day France, Germany,
and Italy.
So, Switzerland was the closest refugee for
much of Europe.
Meanwhile, from Switzerland’s perspective,
they didn’t naturally have much going for
them.
They were small, landlocked, and had little
natural resources.
So, when they saw an influx of talented refugees
flooding into the area, they leaned into the
opportunity.
They stood strong in terms of consistent religious
neutrality and this persuaded many wealthy
businessmen to store their money in Switzerland.
Throughout the 1600s, Switzerland continued
to build up their reputation as a safe haven,
but during this time period, the trust in
Switzerland was just that trust.
In 1713, however, Switzerland decided to up
their commitment.
The Council of Geneva would pass legislation
that prohibited Swiss banks from disclosing
client information.
Originally, this was simply designed to provide
depositors with more security and privacy.
Avoiding taxes wasn’t that big of concern
at the time.
In most countries, income taxes weren’t
even a thing.
So, the primary reason wealthy Europeans used
Swiss banks was truly for security.
Near the end of the 1700s, we saw the American
and French Revolutions, a plethora of political
disputes, and dozens of wars across Europe.
So, during these uncertain times, storing
your money in a neutral place was extremely
important.
Moving onto the 1800s, this is when countries
around the world really started to levy income
taxes.
The US, for instance, implemented the first
income tax of 3% on August 5, 1861.
Though income taxes started out at just a
couple of percent per year, it didn’t take
long for them to grow into the double digits.
And, by the end of the 1800s, people were
looking for clever ways to avoid paying income
taxes to the government.
Given the privacy and security of Swiss banks,
they became the first target for tax evasion
schemes.
For the first couple of decades, neighboring
countries didn’t do much about individuals
leveraging Swiss bank accounts for tax evasion.
You see, income taxes were a new topic at
the time, and governments around the world
didn’t want to approach the topic too aggressively.
So, they gave Swiss banks quite a bit of slack.
However, as income taxes became more accepted
by society, governments started to crack down
on Swiss banks.
In 1932, for instance, French authorities
raided Swiss banks in Paris and this revealed
massive amounts of untaxed money.
But, this didn’t make things better.
You see, this was during the great depression,
and Switzerland was already seeing large amounts
of capital leaving their banks.
And, they weren’t going to let these countries
come in and take even more.
So, in 1934, Switzerland passed the Swiss
Banking Act of 1934 which made it a crime
to disclose a client’s banking information
to a third party without the client’s consent.
And this gave rise to Switzerland becoming
the tax haven of the world.
Throughout the rest of the 1900s, wealthy
individuals around the world sent their money
over to Switzerland in order to avoid taxes
and/or launder their money.
But, since the 1980s, countries have heavily
clamped down on tax evasion especially with
the help of technology.
Nowadays, every single transaction is logged
and easily traceable by the authorities, so
it’s extremely difficult to even get your
money to Switzerland without the authorities
catching on.
But, even if you somehow get your money there,
now you have to deal with opening an account.
While it’s true that Switzerland doesn’t
really care about whether or not you paid
taxes in your home country, they do care about
how you made the money.
Swiss banks require extensive documentation
regarding the sources of your money, and they
do not put up with criminal activities.
In fact, even if you slide by the Swiss bankers’
screening, your Swiss banking rights won't
hold up if a prosecutor brings up significant
evidence suggesting that your money was made
through illegal sources such as drug trafficking,
organized crime, and securities fraud.
So, money laundering through Swiss banks is
quite difficult and in most cases, you will
be caught just like the Wolf of Wall Street.
If you made your money through legal sources,
however, then you may very well be able to
use Swiss bank accounts to evade taxes.
But, in 99% of cases, multi millionaires and
billionaires who made their money through
legal avenues have no interest in straight
up evading taxes.
Sure, they’ll use every single loophole
they can find in the book, but committing
straight up tax evasion is where they draw
the line, as you know, they don’t want to
go to jail.
Moreover, there’s no point in even having
all that untaxed money in Switzerland.
Let’s say you get past all of the safeguards
in place and successfully move your untaxed
money to a Swiss bank.
How are you going to spend it?
Are you going to move to Switzerland?
Are you going to eventually transfer it back
to your home country?
Whatever you do, every transaction you make
is just going to increase the likelihood of
getting caught.
So, in reality the vast vast majority of money
stored in Swiss banks is not subject to tax
evasion or money laundering.
Something else to consider is that there are
plenty of places where it's way easier to
commit these activities such as the Cayman
Islands.
But then why do the rich love Swiss banks?
Well, there’s three primary reasons for
this love starting with neutrality.
Just like in the 16th century, Switzerland
is still a completely neutral country.
They don’t participate in wars, they don’t
have any allies, they’re not part of the
European Union, and they maintain positive
diplomatic relations with nearly every single
country in the world.
Many countries have followed in Switzerland's
footsteps like Finland, Ireland, and Sweden.
But, Switzerland’s neutrality is by far
the oldest and most respected.
Now, this isn’t that big of a deal for the
US and most western countries.
But for wealthy individuals in countries with
divisive politics, it makes sense to store
your money in a neutral country.
Think about millionaires and billionaires
in countries like Saudi Arabia, Iraq, Afghanistan,
China, and Russia.
Jack Ma and Joseph Tsai, for instance, may
have major ties with Swiss Banks.
We know that Tsai’s private jet is mortgaged
by Credit Suisse.
But who knows how much money these mega billionaires
store in Switzerland.
As you can see, Switzerland’s neutrality
is extremely attractive for many billionaires
around the world.
But this is not that big of a deal for most
western billionaires.
What is a major deal for western billionaires,
however, is inflation.
And with all of the money printing from the
federal reserve and the European Central Bank,
inflation is a bigger threat than ever before.
Now, the federal reserve assures us that inflation
is temporary and that we’ll average 2 to
3% inflation like always.
But even a single year of increased inflation
could be quite costly for rich individuals.
Let’s say inflation runs at 4% instead of
3% for a year.
If you have $1 billion in cash, you just burned
an extra $10 million worth of purchasing power
for no reason.
By putting the $1 billion into a Swiss bank
account, however, you can not only avoid the
extra percentage of inflation but you can
often avoid inflation altogether.
You see, Switzerland takes the value of their
currency and their monetary policy extremely
seriously given that banking is their crown
jewel.
They refuse to print trillions of dollars
to fund eye popping government budgets, and
they’ll basically do anything including
negative interest rates and reducing the money
supply to maintain near zero inflation rates.
This is in stark contrast to any other western
country and this is extremely evident in their
historical currency exchange rate.
If we take a look at the USD to Swiss franc
conversion rate, we’ll see that in the year
2000, a single dollar would give you 1.7 swiss
francs.
Today, a single dollar will only give you
0.9 swiss francs.
In other words, the US dollar nearly halved
in comparison to the Swiss Franc.
If we look at a longer time frame, this disparity
just becomes even larger.
In 1975, a single british pound was equivalent
to approximately 6 swiss francs.
Today, a british pound is only equivalent
to 1.27 swiss francs.
This means that the british pound has nearly
dropped 5x in value compared to the Swiss
franc.
To put that into perspective, even if we measure
from the bottom of the 1974 stock market crash,
you would’ve only grown your money 12x by
perfectly timing the market.
With that being said, if you’re gonna hold
large amounts of cash for a long period of
time, it’s a no brainer to hold it Swiss
Francs.
And that brings me to the final reason the
rich love swiss banks and that’s unparalleled
peace of mind.
Switzerland has one of the strictest reserve
requirements and lending requirements in the
world.
In fact, Switzerland is so confident in their
system that all Swiss bank accounts are insured
100%.
In the US, FDIC insurance only stretched up
to $250,000.
Now, will Swiss banks actually be able to
pay out the promised 100% if things go bad?
I’m not sure, but what I am sure about is
that they will pay out way more than any bank
in any other country in that same situation.
And that’s why $6.5 trillion or 25% of all
global cross border assets are stored in Swiss
Banks today.
Have you guys ever considered opening a Swiss
bank account?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think other countries
should take better care of their currencies
like Switzerland.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.